anthony such a strong performance from
your team especially after being down
earlier in the game
what did you learn about yourselves
tonight uh keep fighting you know
they're a great team they're here for a
reason you know this team plays hard
they play scrappy
um they got a lot of guys who can make
plays for them and they came out very
hot
we came out slow um you know kcp saved
us
he hit them two big threes um in the
first quarter and got us going
and we kind of picked it up on both ends
of the floor so
we can't come out like that game two
like i said this is a great team
they're here for a reason um you know we
want to win this this series
and become champions we have to play
better from the start you mentioned
those two kcp
three-point shots the whole team shot
well from behind the arc tonight 38
how much does that have to be part of
what you guys do going forward yeah if
they're going to get with shots like
that we got to be able to knock them
down
um ron and rondo and ac is getting in
the paint and guys open from three so
you know we work on our shots every game
working on shots pre-game
and practice shoot around and guys got
to be able to make shots and we did that
tonight
we just got us a a good lead um you know
we have to play obviously play better
with the lead we can't
you know let guys come in and and get
too comfortable
we feel like we let kendrick nunn come
in and get comfortable you know
obviously he's a
he's a talented player but um you know
we want to win a championship we had to
be better
you know championship mindset for the
full 4 48 minutes so
but guys made shots tonight and and got
us this win well you were one of them
you finished with 34 points
you by the way had one of the most
historic nba finals debuts
we've seen in the nba you are tied for
third place
elgin baylor and i'm going to give you
the other two names on this list
george miken and shaquille o'neal that's
pretty good company a.d how did you feel
out there tonight
um i felt good first nba finals game
obviously the nerds was there a little
nervous but when the balls tipped up
you know we just go out there and play
basketball and i try to do that tonight
you know i got some good looks early got
to the free throw line a lot
able to to calm down and see the ball go
through the net which opened up you know
the jump shot
um and also opens up opened up the lane
for me
so i just gotta go out there and be
comfortable just knowing that just the
moment i waited for
my entire career and now i'm here so you
know maximizing the opportunity because
it doesn't come around too often
and you know my teammate did a good job
of making sure i was in my comfortable
spots to be successful well you
certainly are off to a good start thank
you so much appreciate it back to you
mike